[Applause]
thank you thank
you should you change your political
faction If You Can't Get No Satisfaction
a new Gallop pole run by horses reveals
only 47% of Americans say they're very
satisfied with their personal lives
that's down three points from a year ago
and damn near the record low set back in
2011 when they cancelled Hannah
Montana yeah 2011 was a bad year this
guy was President this guy was vice
president and this person was only at 20
confirmed
kills no surprise the decline in life
satisfaction coincides with Biden's crap
economy yep today you need three jobs
just to live in a van and that includ
that includes van
salesman okay why did I okay that
however certain groups are happier than
others turns out satisfied people tend
to be higher income earners married
religious college educated older and of
course Democrats and of course they are
satisfied they aren't being called names
by their president aren't hunted by the
FBI aren't imprisoned for their beliefs
and they aren't banned from the Outback
Steakhouse oh wait that's just
cat yeah you don't do that to the
blooming
onion me well the poll also revealed
that Republicans saw their satisfaction
Dro by 10 and that's the biggest drop
since the great khaki shortage of
1812 finally 78% of adults said they're
at least somewhat satisfied but that's
below the trend average of 84% so yeah
something's up because we're down what
could it be is it because life has
become less affordable the American
dream is now a pipe dream is it because
crime has gone mainstream as world wars
Loom or is it because our border is as
secure as Hunter Biden's
pants whatever it means more and more
people aren't satisfied and perhaps
there's only one solution lower your
expectations I mean that's what fox
viewers do when they watch Saturday
nights at
[Applause]
10: yeah in your face
Jimmy cat uh you have a pretty good eye
on these polls what they mean cut
through the BS what's this mean
I just have a hard time believing that
like that number seems high to me yes
yeah like half of Americans are very
satisfied with life they're lazy then
because if you're very satisfied with
your life then you're not trying to make
it better at all I mean like oh this
seems pretty good so I I don't see how
you could look around and like every day
is just we're slow one you know Step
Closer towards an inevitable death and
be like very satisfied with that but I
get why religious people are happier cuz
that's what I'm missing yes well maybe
that should push you in the right
direction I mean
I like I would I just I just don't let's
meet to after and we'll do some reading
yeah Tulsi I I'm actually kind of we've
had huge leaps in technology and and
especially convenience our life gets
easier but the unhappiness grows what do
you think it's be behind this have we
like discarded important things without
a replacement like say
religion yes and there are huge indust
that profit heavily from people being
dissatisfied when you look at uh big
Tech in social media for example it's
constantly the algorithm's constantly
pushing like here are the things that
you don't have or here's the way you
should look but you don't and you're not
enough and this and that all the way to
big Pharma obviously that profits
heavily from people going and saying hey
I'm not happy or I'm depressed or I
don't have this or I wish I had that or
whatever the case may be so as long as
these industries continue to profit it
doesn't really matter how the Dynamics
change people are going to continue to
be told you're not enough yeah it's
interesting even companies that are
supposed to make you happy like Disney
are more interested in not making you
happy what about the social media uh
Tyrus there is this thing where we now
can see other people's success when we
you when I grew up I didn't know what my
neighbors had I had to climb over the
fence and peek yeah usually usually it
wasn't until you spent the night at one
of your friends house you found out your
parents were poor yes true you know so
people kept things tight yeah 47% you
know what cat I I rarely disagree with
you but that probably is about right
because that's the 47% living off the
53% of us that are working all damn
time but not me I'm not bitter at all my
life is great yeah so
happy everything's going my way do you
guys know Jordan Peterson yeah I wonder
what Jordan Peterson would have to say
about this kind of lower rate of
Happiness if only he were here please
well oh I thought he was
here well he's been indoctrinated now
too he was sent to re re-education camp
but you know I think well first you
know get something sticky on your hands
and sort of try to get it off you know
clean your damn room you know maybe cut
down on your pronouns you know maybe
instead of 20 genders there's like nine
you know and get your life in order stop
dating a
feminist stop listening to Robin
D'Angelo but maybe be a little less
white you
know I blame her I blame Robin D'Angelo
yeah we've all been hating ourselves for
the last couple years yeah for uh for
being wh mhm and for being too short or
whatever it is you know that's not why I
hate myself why I I changed my height to
millimeters on Tinder just to trick
trick women you know and I say I'm
Mexican I'm an illegal immigrant in New
York City I have a hotel room in the
plaza I'm getting cash every day this
was free I'm living
life all right coming up Jesse files
another appeal for a crime that wasn't
real hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not not get it anywhere
else